jobs di questo nuovo bisogno di ha
ovviamente nella mia vera camera non è
quella finta guardate posso provare
anche queste cose domina il primo
livello di oggi ragazzi non sono anche
come siamo messi a livello di parti
militari livelli anche perché
ultimamente sono uscite sono benefiche
quindi vorrei in tenere il ritmo è un po
la rappresentazione della mia vita
questa cioè io che tento di prendere la
patente e ci arrivo sempre a un tantino
così non riesco mai porco del demonio a
staccarmi dall'ultima ce l'ho fatta
pensa se morivo adesso girando una
facciata per terra sarebbe stato
bellissimo poi trovato ok becchetti
tutto a posto per la vittoria che porta
la chioma che schiava di roma iddio la
creò halloween porco dei quali proprio
lui allora bellissimo che non c'è che
parte per le saux sfera per dirti buon
buona fortuna ok no io è veramente
difficile livello non so come mai
ragazzi hanno queen
forse lei finisce proprio la palla sulla
vittoria cosa devo fare un sito ad hoc
ma quante morti ci sono porco demonio
rugby e non mi [ __ ] la palla non ho
bona e basta eccolo più cinque palle
questo è buono questo buono però se
sblocco la vittoria al cro le mani dello
sport alla vittoria non riuscirò mai
tante palle ce l'ho fatta
a posto ci ho messo due ore e mezza però
ce lo fa riparlate riuscirci ragazzi
nella vita per i nostri ascom demonio
che è successo anche questo è successo
sono bambini cattivi
a me non king matthew booth factor marco
demarie chi era go google agenti da ma
cos'è sta roba si nega comunque
benissimo che devo partire quei
ballerini arrabbiati con una mannaia per
quale motivo made the woodcutter ok
tutto a posto
no sono vivo ho rotto la ruota davanti
però bizet schiacciata non fa niente
brumotti over my t ninjas aia porco del
demonio sono vivo
togliti togliti che arpionato al bene è
più che sia sempre comunque un gioco
educativo ragazzi seguite bbc sky rock
swing rossin nel cielo questi rumori vi
fanno veramente prender male però suoi
rumori delle bombe di via veloci a
prescindere good luck e grazie look e
speriamo che muori
ma cos'è ma per quanto fatto male
quell'aereo lo facciamo meglio io reaser
reit five ma con un aereo così ti voto
al massimo due stelle me però non lo
youtube ai fini non ho mai avuto un
account di happiness e potrei farci un
video solo sull'apertura dell'account
talmente una roba epocale
però continuiamo a fare i livelli perché
secondo me la cavo abbastanza verso
l'interno molto bravo effettivamente a
parte 9 però perché ormai sono conosco
la così felici impossible
non puoi superare quella roba è tutto ok
tutto a posto
lo stesso tipo il coin roberi devono
rubare una moneta tutto sto casino per
rubare un soldo
perché fa vj a rubare un po se la cava
news di art food scusa gli arpioni in
che senso ha per raggiungere il top
eccolo io sono versioni ste cagate di
livelli non so come mai fermi su il
questa è la ruota panoramica
teoricamente ci sono o no tra tutti
avrei preferito avere una bella donzella
in un tema chissenefrega
non siamo così cattivi concia che alla
fine non ci accompagna in un sacco di
avventure quindi perché dovremmo essere
cattivi con lui però in tutto questo
prove del sesto a dondolare questa fare
per farti cadere sarebbe molto carino a
dio mio
sarebbe una figura che se mettendo
ancora un pochettino riesco a salirci
sopra
o forse sì ad andare a importunare gli
altri di fianco può essere aspetto che
si gira la ruota che entro la dall'altra
parte tipo un escape the box al
contrario fermi
spingi ti spingi di porco demonio ce
l'ho fatta
non son riuscito e sono uscito prima e
non sono più uscita eccolo ci sono che
pensate di cominciare senza di me
via porco demonio sono vivo tutto bene
ragazzi siamo su un importo di borse è
un po difficile fare la sua prima volta
però alla seconda anche hai visto 97 per
cento fossimo questo 33 un altro se ve
lo vedete che sono sempre più fateci
caso come ultimamente hanno tutti questo
stampo di prossimo non so perché poi
sempre
e lo fa sotto mentite spoglie realtà lo
fa solo uno che se io sono negata
sennò non capisco perché sono tutti
uguali forse ne faccia un altro uguale
prova mai inneggiando jump sulla mina
come arrivo la non ci si può arrivare lì
o forse sì orco delle mappe
vabbè ma che braccia c'hai di burro mi
sono speso un soffitto e cosa succede
no non ci credo io non ci credo come ho
fatto a morire come ho fatto a morire è
impossibile
mi ripeto di crederci cioè io sono
riuscito a morire che ero più di là che
di qua non è possibile dai a dio santi
ma pensa se andavo d'altra parte adesso
non sarebbe stato ridicolo chamber swing
oddio devo su in gare sta roba come thor
ah no lo devo tenere per andare avanti
pò getting over it ma come credo e poi
magari non è così però teoricamente
dovrebbe essere così devo andare avanti
di quart e giusto
il suo nome non so se non ne sono
proprio completamente sicuro nassi sito
mandare avanti di qua per forza un
livello molto
che fastidio giocare su di me dopo
difficile avanzare ma poi diavolo che
gli è venuto in mente sta roba
ci vogliono 20 anni di terapia per
uscire al suo livello
eccolo vedo il traguardo madonna proprio
lui a rai dondolati ti lanci aiuto ce
l'ho fatta che culo non vi fosse anche
rappate non avrei mai vinto bellissimo
va bene the jump facciamo l'ultimo
ragazzi video commercio
[Musica]
ricordatevi solite bisogno delle lezioni
di happy with chiamatevi vorrei chiudere
con un quiz su ander dale che non ho
perfetto ragazzi spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto la mia conoscenza di andate
e profonda c'è chi vi sia piaciuto
lanciate un commento vi piace anche al
ritorno anche con descrizione non se lo
volessi fischietti e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video della
ragazza
[Musica]